what's happening reject nation Greg
albick here so today I'm gonna check out
the honest trailers for stranger things
yay I'm excited to check this out
because I really do love stranger things
I finished all the season two I know I
put up my reaction review for starting
at Episode five I shot the other ones
it's just there's a lot of footage and I
kind of want to release them all on one
day I just got to assemble it'll
probably have it up by this weekend or
something keep a lookout for that and by
the way patron of the day shout out it's
gonna go out to Erica Tuesday Erica I
will bring John out of his room he's not
here with me because he has not even
caught up on season one Oh stranger
things new that hurt I should really
enjoy when they do cover TV shows the
following trailer only squirrels he's in
one of stranger things the bad man will
get us if we should see two before it's
on blu-ray sweet today's episode is
brought to you by t-mobile America's
best actually meet up with John Bailey
later phone on his rift stream from the
streaming service that's a game of
Thrones away from ruling all of
television tino any reference to bill
you actually see john that every other
day wanna skip intro this song is
awesome okay
love and hate that netflix does that you
love steven spielberg sure do love most
maxim of aperture
now you're all grown up and the real
world is terrible so escape double-speed
get it into your brain Sooners must
revisit childhood may be cool to
re-release it with a video quality a
small town where nobody seems to pay any
mind to the giant high-security
top-secret lab with where one character
disappears that's what I said yeah one
character is missing teeth one character
is cool and skeptical and one character
is a dangerous liability will may be
missing but there's plenty of other
strange things to go around like my
sister trapped in a love triangle
between two haircuts mom who their sons
loss by getting really in the arts and
grass Harbor that cop won a one-man
quest a clap every guard in town a fan
favorite board the most talked about
character with the least amount of
screen time since both he's awkward and
she didn't deserve it I just were
helping a lost child use great
where's the hashtag justice for Betty
huh suit up with 2016's breakout
character slash Halloween costume 11
she's one part Cary
one part the kid for boyhood and was
part of a balanced breakfast spans were
looking at me outside the secret lab she
was raised in discovery our readership
family and for new ways to murder people
oh wow she just straight-up exploded
their brain - gee can we just cut back
to her doing something cute again that's
just like our oh we're covered in snot
ropes and dangerous it's a dangerous
world that can only be crossed into the
woods
monster who is either unkillable
predator wait until puberty is on your
tail clock's ticking Dustin I totally
forgot they kissed story bike Slender
Man slender man then anime character
with no face
[Music]
[Music]
Mike's idiot a Loki stealing the show I
hope yeah right
[Music]
being able to talk to Mike's mom you can
talk to me there's a lot of repetition
in this show yes
now she mastered that look though that's
a badass look these shots from ET Jaws
Halloween eat Nightmare on Elm Street
stand by me and American Werewolf in
London and et
[Music]
his name's Yoda he can use the force to
move things for this mind and the only
way pop culture knows how to explain
alternate dimensions you create a
doorway spacecraft for 2017 and show
kids dabbing on a hoverboard like it
wasn't the worst time ever today's
episode is brought to you by t-mobile
switch to America's best unlimited
network leggo my eggo perfect video
today another dog tomatoes are just
weird apples after your hair is winter
fire January embers my heart burns there
too I gotta say I really do feel this
that might have been one of their best
honest trailers I've ever seen them dude
just in my personal opinion it always
depends the writing of the honest
trailers is a total factor everything of
course it also factors in with you know
do I love stranger things and are these
things I've noticed I thought it was
such a great balance of really strong
observation cuz you got a lot more to
cover in the course of several episodes
as opposed to one movie that were used
to with honest trailers but this really
did nail down the show of course
highlights a lot of the things that we
already make fun of that we already know
but there's also a lot of repetition
things I didn't fully grasp I get kind
of a nova note a rider the way she says
will I didn't fully catch on to that one
no no stare so I was like is that I
didn't notice all those shots either
that are straight out of other movies
and that they're in direct reference to
I mean some shots I noticed but a lot of
them straight out of that movie I don't
know if other people have reference will
as that character and the hangover that
goes missing and he's not really
considered a part of the main gang
necessarily I thought it was really
funny how they really broke it down into
the whole cast is kind of like the
hangover actually I never put that
together I mean I'm in no way saying
it's a direct reference to the hangover
it is just kind of odd how it is pretty
similar in certain
what I really loved in here is the
beginning of this honest trailer says
they're going to only spoil season 1 but
it's funny yeah they're kind of spoiling
things that go on in season 2 they're
actually straight-up spoiling it if you
hadn't seen season do there do an honest
trailer jokes of season 2 within this
season one on his trailers bit just
looking over the footage my mind would
think about these things and then they
were pointed out right then and there I
really did love those jokes a hell of a
lot and that bit about Mike's idiot dad
there's something about that character
at one point in stranger things season -
dusty flat-out tells him you're useless
you know that I thought it was one of
the funniest moments of the entirety of
season 2 because he is kind of useless
he doesn't really seem to have strong
reactions to things he's kind of seems
like it doesn't really care about
anything when he's there it's just kind
of amusing and really funny to watch and
Nancy looking conflicted I'm not like a
lot of other people who seem to really
not like that character a lot I don't
have like a strong issue with I'm not
gravitated towards her cared for me yeah
she's really pretty to look at and she's
a good actress I think I don't hate her
character although conflicted face is
rather similar even in season two I love
this honest trailer - pointed out so
many things that we've already thought
about in more detail and pointed out
things I didn't even really notice but
they're right and some of the best jokes
I've heard yeah that was that was one
hell of an honest trailer before this
video wraps up job you come here do a
shot for air at the Tuesday Erica I
haven't ever talked to you about
stranger things but you look like the
type of girl who would be into stranger
things down with 11 yeah so I just
assumed you were yorda stranger things
so I wanted to give you a shout out my
dear I think you are one hell of a
wonderful human being you are I saw your
private Facebook message you sent me
saying how cute you thought I am and how
much you wish that I wasn't John's best
friend or else it would be weird to try
to hook up with me I had to put you down
softly and you kept going and going and
so I'm sorry I had to block you on
Facebook just now I still really care
and
you just not in the same way you feel
about me emotionally and sexually John
all right there's no there's a whole lot
to unpack yeah I love you too
thanks for not sending me uncomfortable
face oh yeah yeah we're we're past that
now we say on each other you know I lost
weight you know I'm better-looking now
happen yeah yeah I imagine it happens
with everybody you've met previous who
meets you again yeah they also have a
lot more people to suddenly think I'm
better look but keep up the good work
with being an amazing human being and
making amazing a part for the workers of
dreams
check out her Facebook page Erica
Tuesday's got a lot of great artwork on
there seriously check out her she does a
lot of great cartoon stuff and a lot of
great like McCobb and more serious stuff
as well I'll close out this video I do
stranger things season 1 best TV all the
time ever you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bow to
get notified every time a review or a
video is out you can also follow us on
Twitter and Instagram and check out our
patreon guys check out our patreon you
might get a shout out just like this one
follow us and start us - we'd be
reacting to TV and all sorts of things
luck good job